a black hole is a Celestial Whirlpool of
gravitational death
things can go in but they can't get out
but it turns out that one of the most
powerful things in the universe could
have a mysterious twin
a white hole
yeah this Beast isn't exactly like a
black hole black holes are incredibly
dense objects that squeeze all the
matter they ingest into an infinitely
small point at their Center a
singularity
most black holes are remnants of massive
collapsed Stars so they have a lot of
mass condensed into that point and a lot
of mass means a lot of gravity
every black hole has an event horizon
this is the boundaries surrounding them
that marks the point of no return
to escape from The Event Horizon you'd
need to be able to travel faster than
the speed of light
white holes are the opposite in the same
way that nothing can leave a black hole
nothing can enter a white one
that's why scientists theorize that
white holes might be the other side of a
black hole
rather than consuming matter a white
hole constantly ejects it into the
universe
if not back into our universe it could
be a gateway to another
now what we've observed and even
captured an image of a black hole
we've never seen a trace of one of its
white twins
but scientists may have finally found
the evidence they've been looking for
mysterious gamma rays showing up where
they shouldn't be
gamma-ray bursts are short-lived bursts
of gamma-ray light that last from a
fraction of a second to a few minutes
and in this short time they eject as
much energy as our sun does over its
entire lifetime
gamma-ray bursts are the most energetic
events in the universe
they could be hundreds of times brighter
than a supernova and they happen when a
black hole is born
but scientists found one very unusual
gamma-ray burst it seemed to appear out
of nowhere only to collapse on itself
very quickly
and even though it lasted about 100
seconds it behaved like a much shorter
burst
this particular gamma-ray burst called
grb060614 didn't have the usual
Afterglow that comes from a black hole
and that's why scientists think this
might be the proof we needed of a white
hole
so it's time to check it out firsthand
hey before you jump into one of the most
puzzling objects in the universe let me
thank xcats for partnering with us on
this episode you know what's better than
watching my videos well making money
while you're at it with xcad you can do
just that this free app lets you earn
tokens by watching my content all you
need to do is hit that link below
download xcad and sign in with your
email make sure to watch my videos to
earn tokens and you can watch other
creators too once you have enough tokens
you can swap them for cash or cool perks
like personalized video messages social
media shout outs or even a FaceTime call
or if you just want to earn while
watching well you can upgrade and get an
xcad nerd which multiplies your earning
potential don't wait download from the
link in the description press play from
the main menu and start making money now
this trip to the white hole is going to
be costly
if you traveled across the universe to
catch a glimpse of this theoretical
white hole
what you'd find would look like a black
hole a dark emptiness a ring of dust and
gas separated by an event horizon
but you wouldn't slide into the center
of the singularity
no instead things would get rough
your spaceship would be blasted by
intense gamma rays destroying it and
everything inside now even if you could
survive that with the help of super
Advanced gamma protective technology
that doesn't exist yet you'd still never
be able to enter the Event Horizon of
this white hole
it would be like immense air resistance
back here on Earth
the ejected radiation would constantly
slow you down add to that the challenge
of moving through space-time that's
being warped around you and it would
almost be like you were traveling uphill
with an extreme wind blowing you away
you'd need more energy to overcome this
resistance and push forward and the
closer to the white hole you get the
more energy you'd require
there would come a point where you'd
need more energy than there is in the
entire universe
but there might be another way in
if a white hole truly is the backside of
a black hole then traveling into its
Singularity would be like going through
a black hole in reverse
but now Not only would you be competing
against the powerful forces of gamma
radiation but you'd also need to
overcome the impossibly powerful forces
of gravity working against you
oh and you'd need to travel faster than
the speed of light
of course that's impossible nothing can
travel faster than light but you might
be able to get to your destination by
jumping into a black hole first
scientists think that there might be a
wormhole connecting the white hole to
its black hole companion this could be
your only way in
except this passage would be extremely
unstable
the entire thing could collapse
unpredictably at any moment I doubt
you'd want to be inside when that goes
down
don't say I didn't warn you
if you were brave enough to jump into a
black hole well you'd have to pass its
Event Horizon
once you were inside you'd see another
energetic burst of bright light
after this the black hole would seem to
expand all around you surrounded by a
ring of light
you'd be feeling pretty disoriented by
now and it might almost appear as if you
were free falling back through the black
hole
this wouldn't be the case this is just
an optical illusion known as
relativistic beaming
and of course this wouldn't be the only
extreme effect you'd experience you'd
still need to do the impossible and
somehow break the cosmic speed record
traveling faster than the speed of light
you'd be overcoming the most extreme
forces of gravity pulling at you from
behind
and because of that your entire body
would be stretched out very thin
this would be reverse spaghettification
and finally the disorienting effects of
the relativistic beaming would make it
appear to shrink ahead of you like
you're getting further and further away
but eventually you'd overcome all that
gravity and blast your way out of the
Event Horizon
and now you'd be spewed out the other
side of the black hole into a completely
different part of our universe
or maybe not even in our universe at all
yay come on you just traveled through a
black hole and then a white hole
anything's possible
13.8 billion years ago all the matter
and radiation that makes up our universe
emerged out of a singularity
maybe you just traveled through the
black hole that created our universe
it sounds like you've got another epic
journey of Discovery ahead of you
but it might not be as easy as you think
it's possible you've entered a universe
with entirely different laws of physics
than the ones we know of
you might be better off checking out
something else that scientists have
discovered
like this terrifying planet that looks
like Earth
but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
foreign